plastic bertrand et ben ali dont vous
adorer ça la musique des années 80 ça
nous rajeunit pas j'écoute nostalgie
maintenant et suivra bientôt au chant de
france et j'en ai plein la bouche mais
je le dis arnout sa mère car il ya
derrière arnaud tsamère on celle au rire
le spectacle l'envi du public de vous
voir comment ça tu vas finir sept frères
nono
c'est là de sa mère noël exactement
bravoure arnaud tsamère noël garde au
sol sont les jeux de merde je suis chaud
puis de bugs leur nature parce qu'on
pense les invités mais il a bien vendu
oui c'est vraiment un oui le kabyle ou
trois fois je trouve mais il est quoi
passer sa principale qualité un le reste
ce qui peut pousser j'ai trouvé ça
parfait je dis pas ça parce qu'il fait
de maître récent et arnaud enfin arnaud
tsamère sa main de sa mère dans neuf
mois non c'est la mère enceinte non
arnaud tsamère elle est comment c'est
arrivé
elles pondent et la porte au plc les bo
que sa mère se lève et ta mère porteuse
[Applaudissements]